[Music]
on today's show i talked to number one
best-selling author and good friend
christy wright we talk about her new
book on work-life balance and how it's
not even a thing we talk about the
different expectations on men and women
kids being a husband a wife we're
talking about everything right here stay
tuned
[Music]
yo
yo yo what's up this is john with the dr
john dolone show we're so glad you're
with us today show about mental health
relationships
boundaries parenting and listen today
i've got a very special guest a good
friend her desk is like two over for me
here in nashville tennessee we share a
building
and um we share ideas and she's awesome
her name is christy wright she's number
one best-selling author and she's got a
new book coming out where she talks
about
unicorns
and magical dust and
work-life balance all three things that
are
not real but that uh
i don't know the universe says we should
have right did the universe say we
should have unicorns and and dust i
don't think so
i don't know i probably screwed that up
a little bit but she's here it's uh it's
an awesome conversation i love talking
to christy she's really really wise and
she gives zero crap she tells the truth
and i love love love that so stay tuned
for my interview with christy wright
right here on the dr john dolone's show
i just tried to say hello and it was
like patriarchal comment
just doing nothing why what are you
doing
that's so good
you feel good about this no no
i'm glad you're my friend i know
do you have people that aren't your
friend that are scared of you
yes do you yes who
and people i was just doing an interview
about this and they
somehow came up by the enneagram and i
was like aids are not terrifying
like people that are into the enneagram
are you an eight yes everybody thinks
they're terrifying i'm like they're not
terrifying i don't think so yeah but
anyway yes people yeah what is it i
don't know enough about this
voodoo witchcraft
is it um
are you born that way
no lady gaga style or is it like could
you become it i don't know that i mean
the the thing with if anybody even cares
but the thing with aids is there's a
trend that you have a wound from your
childhood that taught you that you can't
trust people and so you you your your
strategy to survive on your world is to
not trust people because you don't want
to get hurt again so it's like when you
okay when you talk about it you're kind
of just showing your wound it's not so
much like something to be proud of but
anyway um you know they you know they
have traits like being aggressive
don't know anything about that i don't
think honestly i don't think you're
aggressive though thank you i don't
think you are at all i'm passionate
when's the last time you got super super
mad
like raged out oh gosh besides this
weekend when you were eight miles from
your boat ramp and your boats floating
in the middle of the water that's when i
was stranded
can i ask you this did you look at matt
like your husband and just like this
no no no because here's the thing
i love a good adventure so i'm like oh
how's this gonna turn out i don't know
it's gonna be great now i would not have
been in good mood if our kids were with
us because that is not fun that's just
super stressful yeah but because it
doesn't like we can figure this out i
just love a good adventure i'm like i
think he's gonna run over yeah
yeah literally on the other side of the
dam from where our house is so it's not
even like we could call our neighbors
i would be so pissed
just floating in the middle of the lake
well
so uh how's this for a romantic date
we're just sitting in the middle of the
lake this is not how i saw it going dang
it but then we did end up driving to our
favorite waterfront
super country
restaurant and saw some awesome sites
just country people on a saturday night
line dancing and bad karaoke it's just
so great you didn't y'all dance
uh no no that's not a that's not a big
dancer
um yeah
i'll work on that thanks that'd be great
that'd be
great yeah but i love to dance me and my
girlfriends like when we you know have
girls nights we'll go some dance yeah
well thanks for being on the show yeah
hey hey you've been here seven years
finally had me on
whatever
we have no one we have no one on this
particular week ah christie's christie
sits over there or or
we're like hey can we get some of our my
co-workers on the show and they're like
yeah they're not gonna do your [ __ ] just
just call strangers in america because
it's not true because i told you you and
i could tag team some phone calls
for sure we're gonna have some phone
calls i got some things to say to your
callers
i don't even know the question is but i
got answers okay so just so you know one
time i walked out of the show and
repeated a call
christy and our desks are next to each
other and i repeated a call that i just
had and i was few and i was pissed and i
repeated the call
and the only person in that office more
mad than me was you and you're like you
tell her that i was like yes that's like
give me your phone number yeah i'm gonna
follow right let's call it right now
yeah all right hey so you got something
big let's do this let's talk about your
book real quick yeah and then we'll get
it we'll we'll dig into the human behind
this book um
so dude you got a new book tell me about
it
yeah it's on a topic that that people
have a lot of feelings about life
balance everybody's got feelings about
everything i know that's true but you
know this is so again typical of my
personalities like if there's like an
area of conflict i don't tiptoe around
and i'm like i'm gonna bulldoze right
into it
and here's the thing people can have all
their feelings about the topic of life
balance that's fine but they still keep
asking because it's the number one thing
i'm asked about and has been for ten
years okay so it's life balance right
yes the guilt-free guide to life
balances take back your time the guilt
free go to life balance and what we're
asking we ask about time management and
productivity and efficiency all that
stuff that's fine but we've got deeper
issues going on when it comes to our
calendar and i want to dig into that and
that's what i talk about in the book and
yes i'll help you with your calendar and
all that stuff but i love digging into
the issue behind the issue of why we
feel this way why why do we when we walk
around all day every day feeling like
we're failing yeah at work at home we
just feel like we're failing we have
this narrative that we're failing no
matter what we do we're sure we're doing
the wrong thing we don't know what
balance is we're just sure we don't have
it i'm like i don't know it feels like
something i want to talk about i want to
fix it you know so in this book you you
dress head-on
it so
i'm getting the sense that
balance isn't a thing
not in the way that we understand it
okay so
when i'm asked the question the question
is always asked this way how do you
balance it all balance is a verb how do
you balance it all
and we've got all the analogies walking
in tight ropes spinning plates juggling
balls some balls are plastic some are
glass which ones do you let drop i don't
know john all that sounds stressful
you just rattled off like nine crocheted
pillows
it's just so cute well that's these
cliche answers you get from people that
we see as successful and the truth is
when i look at jugglers they don't look
real happy or balanced or relaxing in
their life i don't want to do that
it looks like it looks stressful and
hard and it also looks like i could do
all that and i've done all that walk the
tightrope spin the plates juggle the
balls
and still feel like something's not
right in my life and still feel like
i'm not balanced whatever that means and
so i started asking a different question
what if balance isn't something you do
how you balance it all
what if instead it's something you
feel what if it's something you create
what if you could be a balanced person
in an out of balance world what if you
could create a sense of balance and
still be busy
what if balance looks more like
peace
being confident in your choices when you
say yes to this thing or the no to that
thing what if it looks more like i don't
know
just being happy
in your life and how you spend your time
and shaking the guilt that's been
following you around for a long time i
think when we ask about balance that's
what we really want we just want to be
proud of how we spend our time in this
one life we've been given we want to
shake this guilt that just haunts us
everywhere we go
and so that is the version of balance
i define in the book and
you stole my book title with your whole
redefining anxiety thing i want it to be
redefining balance but we did we did
come up with something else
[Laughter]
i don't think balance is about balancing
at all as we talk about it i think we
have this pressure
to have this 50 50 split between work at
home or or more common to do everything
for an equal amount of time i'm going to
work out and spend time with the spouse
and spend time at church and spend time
with my kids and spend time at work and
also personal goals and time with god
and
that sounds stressful um and it's not
realistic and so the thesis of the whole
book is life balance isn't
doing everything for an equal amount of
time it's about doing the right things
at the right time and when you do that
you will actually feel that sense of
balance you've been looking for and
that's the kind of balance i walk them
through in this book that's awesome so i
had this this thing happened to me the
other day we i took my first vacation in
forever and we just went to like a
koa me and my family and then we went
with another family with little kids
and we had like a pregame meeting where
the four of us like me and my wife and
and the other couple we all met and said
what are you what are you looking to get
out of uh how did you visualize this how
do you see this vacation planning like
well it was it was basically i could be
weird and awkward
and well my wife is trying to predict i
mean trying to prevent that so what do
you want to get out of this vacation
what do you want to
and
it hit me
in a way that it i've thought about this
before i've talked about but it never it
never hit me and tell me if this
circle's back here if you see this
i think at first blush i wanted to go on
vacation so i could do nothing
the goal was this illusion of nothing
okay
and i would go and i don't i didn't have
a picture of it i just wanted to not be
doing these other things whatever this
is which was
food prep and being around people and
talking and working with it
but i didn't have a thing of what we're
going to go do i just wanted to not be
doing those things which meant i just
want to do nothing and then i've looked
at
the idea like i can't wait to retire
i've had buddies that came out 20 years
from retirement i think i don't i don't
want to just do nothing and i see a
trajectory towards
getting to
like my recliner at the end of every day
like people just can't they work all day
so i can get here and then go to bed and
repeat
it feels like this idea of balance i'm
going to run run run run run run so that
i can get to this place where i don't
have to do anything yeah and i realized
that doing nothing
all the research tells me is that your
body falls apart your mind falls apart
your relationships fall apart then you
just die yeah your goal is to do nothing
right yeah
but i don't know that this idea of
balance this feeling of i'm either
getting to a place where i can finally
do nothing
or i can do things that i want to do and
there will be no stress or pain or
frustration or any
does it make sense what are people
looking for when they say i want balance
yeah yeah so that's that's what's
interesting because when i walk through
this whole redefining what this could
look like we talk about what would it
look like to be have a sense of peace
even in a world that's chaotic or to be
confident your choices even when those
choices are hard but you make a good
point i was actually just talking to
someone earlier today about this i think
sometimes we jump to these conclusions
about certain words and we associate
them with something being really
negative or wrong so for example i'm
tired so that must be something's wrong
or i'm stressed or i'm overwhelmed or
this is a really hard season so i must
be failing as if we have this unspoken
expectation that life is supposed to be
easy and effortless and we know that
it's not in our mind we know
intellectually it's not but then when
things get really hard
we think oh i'm failing this is terrible
and so on and the one of the things i
actually talk about this in the book but
i i want to i want to differentiate
between
just because you're tired doesn't mean
your whole world is out of balance just
because you're stressed doesn't mean
your whole world is out of balance just
because you're overwhelmed doesn't mean
your whole world is out of bounds each
of those things might be a clue if you
felt like that for a decade sure we
might need to figure out what's going on
with you but if you just didn't get
sleep last night you might just need a
nap or it might mean that you worked
really hard that day right you might
have a good thing yes you might have
just had a hard day or you're dealing
with a situation you don't know how to
deal with and so when we can separate
our
uh conclusions about our whole life from
these situations then i think it gives
us a greater sense of power and it
reduces all that guilt so so another
example i would use is when i talk about
seasons
um i've been guilty of this where i look
around me and i draw conclusions about
myself based on the season i'm in so as
an example my house is a mess so i'm a
mess and i'm failing as a mom i'm like
no i am not a mess i have three little
kids that make a mess every day multiple
times a day i am not a mess but if we're
not careful we'll do that we will draw
conclusions about ourselves from our
season and i just want people to know
your season is where you are not who you
are right your season is where you are
not who you are and so this is the
season you're in it's the season of
difficulty in your job or difficulty
with your health or difficulty with the
family member this isn't who you are
but but when we begin to separate
ourselves then we can look at okay
what do i want my life to look like
what's right for me right now
simple powerful question then when you
decide what's right right now then even
when it's hard and even when you're
tired you're going hey but i'm doing the
right thing right now i'm real tired
john like i'm in the middle of book
launch we're in the middle of pre-sale
traveling doing lots of interviews i am
tired yeah but i'm also excited because
i'm like i'm doing what's right right
now it's a good thing yeah good tired
yeah exactly i'll never assume we
pathologize tired
exhaustion yes but tired means you put
it in today yeah and you did i don't
know yeah i think it's a good thing yeah
how is this different for men and women
well you've been working women for a
decade for years yeah so i think that or
is there a difference well i don't know
i mean all of its all of my
thoughts on that are more just kind of
um you know gut intuition but i have
noticed a trend where i hear women say
i'm failing and i don't hear men say
that in that same way not from the same
place of like i'm failing as a dad i'm
failing at work i'm just failing
everywhere whereas women say that and
they say it and they reinforce it and
they all say it to each other that no
you're not no i am but you're not i mean
this narrative that they're failing
haunts them
i do think that um at least at least in
my observations you can tell me if you
feel like this but i think that
men tend to
compartmentalize easier like matt seems
to be able to compartmentalize a little
bit easier whereas when he's at work i
don't i really don't think he's thinking
about us which is awesome gotcha because
he's at work be where your feet are
the more i've tried to practice that the
more balanced i feel where i can
actually be present the moment that i'm
in but i feel like women are often like
our mind is in a million places and
often it's in the places that we're not
so then we feel guilty so i don't know i
mean do you feel like you can compare
several questions to that um
um
i'm taking notes here industry um
so
i used to until i read terence real's
work about overt and covert depression
meaning
um you look at the stats it looks like
on on its face that women experience
depression they experience these seasons
of guilt this i'm i'm a failure
way more than men and what he came out
and said that's absolutely inaccurate
men
have demonstrate depression by puffing
their chest out oh god
by doing by yelling by
numbing
and so where
a man may not men may not put it out
there to the world they may not
verbalize i'm failing they'll go have
nine drinks and disappear in front of a
ball game they'll go golf all day all
day all they'll go hide right
and um so it ends up being the same
thing they just they have different
words for it yeah and so there i it may
not be as identity driven identity might
not drive me to the ground yeah but they
are killing themselves just the same
well when i have given this talk and
this content i've been speaking on this
topic to our entree leadership audiences
from summit to master series whatever
since 2013 so a really long time
different iterations of it um and even
back in the day years ago it used to be
much more male uh audience
it hit a nerve yep big time yep and so
there's something about it that we all
there's something in us that we feel
like there
there's something more for us that we
need something not to do more not to run
harder and faster but like something
feels like it's not right
and i want to fix that feeling and i
don't know what that is and that's
i think that we describe it with balance
i need more work-life balance well you
could take a vacation
you can take time off you can leave at
five
but if you still have that narrative
that you're failing then it doesn't
matter what time you leave work because
you're taking that narrative home with
you and you're bringing it to work with
you the next day you say this all the
time like wherever you go next you're
taking you with you right and if that
story is a story you believe and nurture
and fuel and accept and and live out of
well then the story is what we have to
fix the that idea not just the calendar
one of the things i said the other day
that i thought oh gosh that summarizes
it so well
this is not a calendar issue it's not
just about the calendar it's about
enjoying the life that the calendar
represents i want to help people do that
so how do you help somebody or
it
when i used to travel with with work and
now we travel now i used to
as soon as i'd get on a plane i'd start
writing notes to my kids
i would text my wife i would
start trying to anchor back to where i
was because i was guilty that i was
leaving she with two little kids i was
um guilty i was gonna get to stay in a
hotel by myself and sleep and all those
things
and it occurred to me a couple of years
ago
oh i'm dishonoring whatever group i'm
going to speak to i am
not helping them at home at all i am
making a choice to be more miserable by
trying to be having my heart
back there my work over here
so now when i leave the house i'm out i
am focused on where i'm headed yeah it
feels like there's an industry there's
an ecosystem there's there's air and
water that we breathe and swim in
directed towards women to make sure
you're never where you are
does that make sense there's an industry
of guilt that is surrounds women in a
way that i don't feel yeah yeah you
should be at home with your kids and if
you're not why are you at home with your
kids we worked all this time you should
be a vice president of a company if
you're vice president of a company you
should be wearing this does that make
sense okay i'm not gonna get into the
whole gender thing with this but i am
curious when you travel do people ask
you who's watching the kids they do with
me they do yes but i yes like where are
your kids where's your family yes and i
know who's watching the kids
um
no the assumption is just my wife is 100
i get asked everywhere i go who's
watching the kids uh i don't know the
dog i don't know i just hope they'd work
out like matt never gets asked that
that's never been asked in his whole
stinking life who's watching the kids
i'm like isn't that fascinating there
there i think there is just the
assumption right 100 i think sometimes
it's spoken sometimes it's unspoken and
i'm not mad about i love being a mom
like i love that people you know that's
great but i do think that there is
pressure there and i will tell you that
that is years ago i discovered that's
where so much my guilt came from was
always focused on where i was not so
when i'm at work i'm thinking about my
kids oh are they okay or they you know
did i forget this that are they sick do
they need me then i would go home and
i'd be with them and i'm checking email
and i forgot to write to finish that
chapter and you know i got to respond to
that
so if you are always focused on where
you are not
then of course you feel guilty because
you're always focused on where you're
not and by the way you also are
completely missing the moment that
you're in so the
analogy i use as a is a car
flip your focus instead of always
looking through the rear view mirror of
what you're leaving behind look through
the front windshield of where you're
going
and be where you feed where your feet
are so i'm just like you when i walk out
the door
i intentionally
channel my focus to what i'm going to
yep and then when i go home same thing
it's like i'm shutting this off as much
as i possibly can it it allows you to
not just be more present it allows you
to experience and enjoy those moments
more because you're actually in them now
and by the way you don't feel guilty
because you're like no i'm focused on
the thing i'm doing look i'm doing great
now i'm gonna go home and be doing great
then versus i didn't do that i didn't do
that i'm leaving that behind you know
so tell me tell me about how you grew up
kids mom dad brothers and sisters
no brothers and sisters okay only child
yeah
that explains everything go ahead and
i'm gonna flip it to you next uh
[Laughter]
my
dad and stepmom had a little girl when i
was 16. okay and a baby was 16. so i did
grow up an only child but i have a
half-sister now um my mom
single mom uh started a cake shop when i
was six months old to raise and support
me
and my dad was not in my life from the
time that i was eight until i was 14.
okay so that drastically shaped me yeah
absolutely uh who i was in high school
in college and then even after that but
i have a great relationship with now i
found him when i was 14 and we have a
great relationship now um
yeah i i mean my parents if you met my
parents my mom and my dad
both so similar like adventurous
spontaneous entrepreneurial hard work or
two like a fault like don't know when to
stop it is me like it's just like oh
yeah this christie makes sense like i'm
so i'm so much like
what i watched
so how do you how do you live with
i see this and i feel what that was and
i've experienced what that was
and i'm gonna make
i want this to be different for my kids
and my marriage and my work how do you
balance that
well i think it actually that's what i
just
how do you filter that yeah so i think
one of the things that i have always had
a very strong sense of i think
strong-willed children have this i was a
strong-willed child i am a strong-willed
adult whether any gram whatever you want
to call it i have a very strong sense of
ownership
over my life meaning not like
not like in a territorial way but like i
have a strong sense of a right to myself
so like if i'm parenting my children in
some way and someone judges me i'm like
well you got your own kids you do what
you want with your kids like like these
are these are my kids this is my family
so the reason i bring that up is matt
and i have been very intentional
to say what do we want our family to
look like you talk about this like
visualizing plans for the weekend or
whatever
what do we want our family to be about
and
truly my growing up could not have been
more opposite from mats growing up and
both had good qualities but it's almost
like we've come here yeah into the
middle where it's like we're gonna take
the good from my side and the good from
his side and the parts we didn't like
from each side and try to not do those
things
um
and just try to just try to be better i
mean i think that's what most
generations try to do try to fix them
um
[Music]
i think the conflict
initially
was exhausting it can still be but but
initially trying to navigate that and
discern that was really hard like you
y'all did christmas this way and you all
did house responsibilities this way and
you know i mean
all the communication around that was
exhausting now i think it's more
effortless because we very much are in a
rhythm and we have three kids we've been
doing this a little while we've been
married almost 10 years like we've got a
rhythm of
what we want our family to be about but
i think figuring out what we wanted it
to be about was hard you know because i
don't even know that we knew
like what do you mean like like when i
when we got married it's like you know
in sickness and health we're like yeah
great
[Laughter]
are you ready for kids yeah totally yeah
they're like a dog right but like they
just cry more i don't know we had no
idea
we had no idea what we were doing we had
no idea you just figured as you go but
um
hard conversations
like we were we were willing well
some of us were willing
some of us got
that didn't love that but i mean we i
mean you know we we're different
personality styles he's more an
introvert and extrovert i'm an extrovert
obviously so so what what what when you
look at mom you look at dad and then you
look at you have three little ones
what is one thing you want to make sure
they get that stays on that line
um
i want to say
yes more than i say no
and that's something i good i got for my
mom my mom was a yes mom like it was
like hey let's go get ice cream at you
know eight o'clock yeah like she's a
she's an adventurous mom like she's
spontaneous and i had no rules and i got
myself in debt because i didn't even
know how many works so there's
the responsible side that was not her
sweet we'll get to the other side yeah
yeah yeah but but she was spontaneous
and fun it was like live like it was
like live like like like live every
moment she just has the zest for life i
want my kids to have that so so in my is
that hard for an eight
no that's very i'm eight wings no i'm
like i'm i'm not all in okay oh yeah so
like when my son says um
i don't know i'm probably gonna get hate
mail from this but that's fine tyler
will filter i'm gonna have to when i
like drive i have to get in line
when you're driving like when we're
driving down the road in my neighborhood
it's very my in-law's very small safe
neighborhood and my son carter from the
back seat yells can i stick my head out
the sunroof i'm like yeah
right now my default answer as a tired
mom wants me no because i'm tired
because because it's just easier but i'm
trying to find opportunities to say yes
so when he says can we go do this thing
that's that's maybe takes a little more
effort for me yeah but it'll be fun to a
six-year-old like for example let's use
a better example when my son wanted to
be
waffle house for halloween not a server
the building yeah absolutely that took
some more effort for me to create this
cardboard building
uh i want to be a mom that says yes and
we made that stinking waffle house and
it was awesome like i just want to be a
mom that says yes i can't always say yes
there's plenty of things i have to say
no to
but when i can say yes i want to say yes
yeah i want his childhood to be fun
memories that if i could do it i tried
to do it what's the reverse of that
what's one thing that stops with christy
and matt
oh well
my mom's gonna listen to this
i my family doesn't listen to my show so
i'm i'm good i'm psychotic about being
on time uh picking him up she was always
late to get me i'd be the last kid
picked up after school just so you know
christy was in the studio today before i
was before everybody was before kelly
and james and everybody
christy was here first
uh i wish it translated to everything in
life but there was one day truly carter
was literally two years old in a
preschool and i was gonna be like five
minutes late and i cried the whole way
there like you can just psychoanalyze
that all day but it's like it's like
that is a we will never be late to pick
him up because i don't want him to be
the last one like i just remember that
feeling yeah so
there's lists on both sides of all of it
right like we've got good things bad
things on all oh yeah yeah yeah i'm just
always i'm always interested in what
what people's
what drives people toward what they're
running towards and what they're saying
no yeah okay so another one my mom is
creative
super creative entrepreneurial she's
like imagine any movie you've ever seen
where there's an inventor like she has
patents like the beauty and the beast
the crazy inventor dad like that's her
so her house was always a mess ah and so
i'm like weird about keeping and i'm not
like monica and friends i'm not like i'm
not one of those people i'm not like a
perfectionist i don't but because i grew
up at a mess it's really important to
have straight house which is extremely
hard with three kids under six so i've
had to like reduce my expectations of
even what's realistic but that is
something that like it comes from that
childhood place
of having a messy house that i that i
wouldn't have friends over i want
friends to be able to stop by and they
can come in
and that yeah that's hard
so on being on time and keeping a mess a
clean place two things
john delaney's not doing before hey
we'll be right back
whatever dude whatever the show's called
we'll be right back
hey what's up i want to take a quick
break to talk about the most important
question i'm asked almost every day how
do i find a counselor if you can't find
a counselor in your area or you can't
afford one i've got a solution for you
i've partnered with a better help for
customized online therapy video chat
text chat phone counseling it's a
licensed therapist whenever and wherever
you need them go to betterhelp.com
deloney for 10 off your first month it's
cheaper and it's available all the time
this is for you your family and for
everyone else that's coming your way
take care of your mental health go to
betterhelp.com
[Laughter]
tell me about the shoes off
it was an accident it was yeah we were
we were in between shots and did you
live on the cover when you do the shoot
did you kick somebody no that would have
been a better story but um we had all
these different shoes we were taking
pictures of all the different shoes and
different outfits and we were in between
and i was literally just standing there
and then seth started taking photos
we're like oh that could be cool like
that could be cool with shoes off like
oh you know like you know at the end of
the day switching gears between
work at home and whatever
and we liked it so we just tried it a
few more times and then got that and i
love it and it's funny because i had a
friend tell me when she saw that she
goes i was showing her all the covers
there was like six we were testing and
she said that was my favorite by far she
said because
only if you have seen that you
understand the freedom of getting home
at the end of the day and kicking your
shoes off like the feeling of just like
okay
switching gears yeah i'm here yeah
taking your hat off whatever yeah james
do you kick your
your shoes off every day
i do
you don't you sleep in shoes don't you
your next book cover i want you to be
wearing the the vibram shoes with the
toes
oh my gosh do you have those you so
would have those
you seem like the kind of guy that would
have those that running book that got so
popular all my running friends were
running barefoot and in the vibram shoes
even on trails i'm like how did they do
they were incredible weren't they
i didn't do it you didn't do it
all right i didn't get him on the trend
i just used tennis shoes
running shoes
okay so you give
it
advice for a living no okay
and
you give advice for a living it's what
you do
and
[Laughter]
exactly right what i've learned is the
things that make me successful at work
right like having to deal with a
producer that doesn't even listen to and
or like this show sure i mean kelly the
associate producer who literally
despises the the hour she's in here with
me
um
like
or when people are they're they're
giving you six photos to deal with the
photo shoot and you're a writer and
you've got editors saying we want to say
it like this you're like no i wrote it
like this and
um then you're talking to business
leaders what i've learned is
the things that make me successful at
work and this is back when i was a
professor this was back when i was a
minister
can melt
my family right if i come home and i'm
always
like sheila says hey i'm struggling with
this i'm like well you know and i treat
her like a collar
i will be sleeping on the couch not no
not inside at all in the barn with the
chickens right
um
how do you balance
gosh i need to stop doing it you just
keep doing something
i'm enjoying it now
how do you shift gears to get out of i
am the same things that make me
successful at my work
to now i'm
a mom now i'm a wife now i'm a friend so
one of the exercises i went through and
this actually came out of untrained
leadership summit last year my talk for
that so that was before i wrote this
book okay i wrote this talk this is the
background to it
um
i think asking people if you tell people
you know
figure out what matters and spend your
life on those things which is
essentially what i'm saying in this book
and showing you the steps to do it that
can be hard people say well what does
matter well what's important to me what
what do i want for my life they don't
know right
so i said what if you ask a different
question and i asked this on stage and
it really resonated and then it's and
it's something i've been doing too
instead of saying what do i need to do
what do i need to spend my time on you
know what are my priorities what do i
want all that stuff which can be really
hard to answer
especially when you're busy and you're
in the weeds instead ask yourself a
different question
who do i want to be
who do i want to be to my kids
and when i it's almost this out of body
experience of like saying like looking
at myself more objectively instead of
who do i think i am i think i'm failing
i think i'm this whatever it's like who
do i want to be
and and that's another common thing i
have seen from at least the women that i
work with
they say things all the time like i'm
not a fun mom i'm not a business owner
i'm not a runner and i'm all i can think
is says who go do something fun and boom
you're a fun mom go put your idea out
there go run it into the street you can
fix this right now
so instead of thinking about like who do
you think you are
and living within those labels we put on
ourselves or those limitations we think
we have then instead just say what who
do i want to be
and so when i wrote a list of who i want
to be to my kids
that then determines what i do when i
get home because then i
act like the person i want to be so if i
want to be happy if i want to be fun if
i want to be present if i want to then i
act out of that intention of that what i
decided i wanted to be and then what's
interesting is i become that because our
actions determine who we are so it's
like i choose
who i want to be and act in line with
that and then i just
by default become that and it's not
perfect at all no but it but it's it's
directional but if i don't decide that i
will come home i'm like well we're doing
this and then this and then this and you
need to get fix your clothes like i
would be drill sergeant because at work
i'm so switching gears so fast now i've
got to do this now i've got to write i'm
so task oriented at work and we run so
hard and fast here
that like i would not
be present in the moment with my kids i
would not be able to enjoy the
spontaneity enjoy the when my when my
son takes i don't know seven and a half
hours to walk down the stairs which i'm
like how how could you move slower an
actual snail could be beating you right
now like but it forces you to slow down
and just be with them in their world and
what's important to them
and what sounds fun to them versus your
ideas about what should be important and
whatever so i think that question has
really helped me who do i want to be and
i can do you can do the same thing at
work you can do it anywhere who do i
want to be i read a book this weekend
and it was fascinating um
and they talked about
there's two different brain circuits and
and i hate to use those tech or
mechanistic metaphors for humans but
so when you use the word i
like i am i am in i am can't believe i
said that okay if i did that i'm late to
pick up my kids again
that that feeling of in it triggers a
fight-or-flight response your cortisol
adrenaline you are in it
when you use words like you
or
when you talk to yourself hey christy
you actually solve that problem over
there and it doesn't trigger your
response interesting or when you go
future so
two examples of this i've seen is when
me and sheila are in the middle of
something and i i think what is
happening in my marriage right now and
then i come to work and someone says hey
can you help me me my wife are and i can
go yeah this this and this because when
i'm in it i've got a hormonal chemical
response to this to to fight it or run
from it when i'm over here i'm distance
from it my body can
doesn't unhook my frontal lobe right
right i'm in it i can answer those
questions and what you just said is a is
a awesome way of distancing yourself
from and it lets you just go huh i can
be a part of this one in this one and
this one otherwise except when i'm in it
i'm gonna start solving this thing right
because i gotta i gotta be i gotta be
fighting it or running from it or
freezing it with it and
um it seems like a gentler way right
well it's interesting that you say that
because i think for me one of the things
that is helpful about it is you don't
feel held back by who you think you are
like oh i feel like i feel like i'm
failing or whatever all these things are
but it also just helps you decide that
that you can
you can become that person you can you
can decide who you're going to become
and you can do that and i think that for
a lot of people that feel like
they're not a good mom or they're
failing or whatever that narrative is
not even true but if you can act in line
with whatever you think that is then it
just gives you more permission one of
the things that i i talk about
in the book that i'm so guilty of is
sometimes if i'm not careful
i will for example i will focus on the
wrong thing
in any given moment
and and by doing that it not only steals
my sense of balance and all that but it
actually turns me into someone that i
don't like so let me give you an extreme
example
uh last year at christmas i wanted to
like all moms for the record i want to
get a picture of all my kids and
matching christmas pajamas in front of
the christmas tree i realize this is a
big ask but i just want to make it
happen okay these dreams are real all
the women can relate right now so like
okay guys i'm bribing i'm rewarding i'm
you're doing great here we go i they
don't even need to be perfect but just
everybody looking in the general
vicinity of camera oh no oh no 600
attempts ornaments are flying off
conley's kicked his brother mary grace
is screaming somewhat like it's mass
chaos and because i'm trying so hard
to capture this photo to show what a fun
time we're having
i created a situation that is the exact
opposite of fun right and by the way
turned myself into someone that i don't
like yeah and so
let's use that example separate yourself
from that go
who do i want to be in that moment i
want to be a mom that's like snapping
pictures of what's actually happening
and if we capture one cool like like now
my new photo rule is three i try three
times and i quit if i get it great if i
don't i don't and we move on and those
pictures will be equally if not more fun
to talk about in 30 years 100 right 100
there's a um do you ever watch the show
uh little fires everywhere no okay well
there's a scene reese witherspoon pet
plays elena and there's that exact scene
where she ends up screaming and cussing
at her daughter in front of the
christmas tree this thing that's an
extreme example but we all do it where
we get caught up in things
that we think are important that are not
but because we're so focused on that
obsessed with that spending time on that
energy money whatever that is and you
can fill the blank with a million
different examples
we become someone we don't like so
instead i just want to decide who i want
to be someone that i would like that i'd
be proud to be and then just what would
that person do how can i act in line
with that idea not ahead of who i want
to be versus reacting to
all these unimportant things that i get
caught up in that i think is so easy to
get caught up in dude i love that
so who keeps you accountable that do you
and matt have a code word
who do you allow into your life that
says chrissy we're done
or do you have that
matt doesn't have to say it he has a
look yeah he has a look does that piss
you off though yes because you're trying
to get your pictures done like yes
i'm like you don't understand you know
what else he does what else you don't
understand he's like i do what are we
doing
we have these codes and he never like he
never like taught me the codes i just
picked up on the codes after 10 years
one of them is a look when it's like
you're being too much like all all this
about the christmas like he'll just look
like or he might just go babe
and i know that look it's like it's ever
you know what else he does he'll be at
dinner like this i'm like let's say
group of friends he'll just
gently place his hand on my leg and i
know that means i'm being way too loud
he never told me the hand on the leg
means you're being too loud but i just i
did notice a pattern that i would be at
a very loud volume when the hand always
came on my legs i was like okay i'll
just bring it down a notch sheila gives
me the the you're being a lot for
everyone it's just a it's a pressure on
my shoulder and it's just like
hey hey and that's uh all the things
come out of your mouth you're gonna
regret tomorrow
and um i don't even think you're you're
with us anymore matt is so brilliant
because he didn't have to say a word
yeah it's just it's a it's a look or
it's a hand on my leg like i know the
first 15 years that happened i got raged
out like
exact and now i'm like you're exactly
right i'm sorry yeah well like if i when
i you know i don't know need to
rearrange our side tables or throw
pillows for the 400th time i'll be like
bam i think they look great i'm like
that's right
see and i would tell matt to take a dive
on that one like let's let him let him
ride dude that's right
one time he came
true story this is a few months ago he
came downstairs and i go do you like
that side table he goes i do i also like
numbers 4 7 19 and 29. i liked all of
those every
all the options we've had rotating
through the last few months okay so what
makes you a good mom
what makes you good at momming
can i give you two things you can give
as many as you want
there are two things that i really pride
myself in that i think is just i think
will matter later i hope it does because
i'm really trying hard at it
being present i know we've talked about
that but like i'm with them
i'm in it yeah i'm in it like whatever
story you're telling me like i'm i'm
winning in it
also being fun like their version of fun
so like i'm not a sit back and watch
them play i am in it like i am like we
are making up games and scavenger hunts
and building forts out of cardboard
boxes like i'm super creative so i just
i just i just want to be fun
what makes you a good wife
like a good partner for matt
i
okay i encourage
anything he wants to do now granted the
caveat to that is he doesn't ask for
much so if he's like i want to take a
guy's trip i'm like yes go golf yes buy
the fancy smoker grill yes yes yes like
the smoker i don't know what is it
called the komodo whatever that is
yeah i just i anything he wants and he
makes it easy because he doesn't hardly
ask for anything you know what i mean so
it's sometimes like you should you know
like
i just i really i really try to
encourage and affirm him he's one of
those people that like he's always like
puts everybody's needs before his own
yeah he's a deep sense of responsibility
like that would be your responsibility
please go go run do the trail running
group go on a guy's trip go golf go
yeah i just but but i that goes both
ways i i want to be able to do that and
i want him to be able to do that i want
us both to have a healthy
other parts of our lives than just each
other in home responsibilities all the
time what's what then you're trying to
get better at being a mom
um
a typical enneagram eight but my anger
like i'm not proud of that but man when
you're tired
and like they're just screaming and
they're just wiping peanut butter on the
walls
the walls you just clean yeah
or my son connolly will just like go
through a room and literally just like
throw everything on the floor like with
the bookshelves anything just like just
it's like they're just actual tornadoes
and and and most of the time i'm like
like you know you read all these
parenting books and they're like well
just like you know just ask them how
they're feeling i'm like
i want to hear how they're feeling i
just every now and then i'll snap and
i'll just scream
so do you do you get do you get angry at
what they did do you get angry at
that you had a picture of what this was
going to look like and now it's
different like what do you get angry at
because i find myself there too
and
what what do you what do you what does
that
that thing come from or is it just a
it's your kids demonstrate hey how
little you actually control in the world
like what what's the anger for all all
of the above option d all of the above
but i will tell you the one that is the
most maddening to me
is undoing work i've done and i think
that's because i'm so tired and so like
when i'm really tired and i pick up you
know all the toy whatever and they come
through and literally just throw it all
out
like that that's maddening because i'm
like i was so tired and and and dug so
deep to be able to do that whatever the
thing is fill in the blanks whatever it
is you know it could be any number of
things it's not just cleaning it's not
just toys it's like anything like i'll
i'll get car you know get colleen all
dressed for the day and then the next
thing i know he's literally just like
wiping you know yogurt on his shirt and
i'm like
the whole thing yet that's right
yep
that that that that cuts me deep because
i'm just like i have to do it like it's
it's you go insane because you're like
i'm doing the same thing and getting the
same results
over and over and over again but i don't
want to i'm trying to do something new
but they just and i find myself trying
to do
explain algorithms and there's a child
going huh yeah like i don't what and you
have to go oh you're five or you're
three you don't know what i'm talking
about right right yeah what about what
about um like uh um
oh james just last questioned me in my
ear oh make it a good one all right i'll
make it a good one here let's see here
um
what's one thing you have
okay
okay
well he has something similar so we
don't do because he has something
similar what are you good at parenting
that's being fun and present i'm active
see what's what is um what's something
you
two things one you've what's something
you've changed your mind on last five or
ten years you speak publicly you have a
show
um a fancy famous show you've got a
like jillions of devoted people who
pattern their life after you what's one
thing you've changed your mind on and
then one thing one thing you have been
out in the public sphere
and
you've come back to me like i think i
was wrong on that
but you've had to circle back and say
i was on stage and i said this a lot and
then i don't think i was right on that
okay
um let's do the first one i feel like
this could even be both of them i get
well not the second one um
the first one i mean this is getting
into like you know just
a topic that is super polarizing in our
world but um so i grew up in a really
diverse high school i was the only white
girl on our track team i had a ton of
black friends growing up so i never
thought
i had any
ignorance
when it came to race in america like i
would have thought i am cultured if
anyone gets it i do yeah and it's not
like i'm an expert but when when
everything was coming out last year
about racism and all of the
um the experience of an average black
person in america
i would have thought
i
i could see that i could understand like
like not like i've experienced it at all
but i didn't feel ignorant gotcha and
then i began actively seeking out
content teaching wisdom leadership from
tons of people that i've never gotten
that from black americans that are
leading in these spaces and teaching and
you know it was just being talked about
everywhere yeah
and my eyes were so open to some of the
experiences they had that i never knew
they had like for example even you know
friends that i had in high school one of
my best girlfriends today like i look at
her differently now going like oh my
gosh like because we never talked about
it in the context of a friendship i
guess i'd never knew it was there gotcha
and then i've since brought up some of
those topics with my friends been like
have you had these types of experiences
or these types of comments or people
following you know just some of the
things that i didn't
i would have i would have never known i
had those blind spots and i did and so
it's been very eye-opening to me to
learn you know yeah yeah what's
something you said from stage 10 years
ago that now you think i'd probably do
that differently
all of my first three years of talks
[Laughter]
i don't know
here's the perception if once you get a
show once you get some books once you
make the best seller list which this one
for sure will be on there again you've
been number one national bestseller
multiple times over when you do these
things
that you quote unquote get there right
you
arrive and
people don't understand like the
oh my i just said this a lot on a stage
on a live stream that that's been being
repackaged and sold and i'm talking this
about myself here
i wish i'd said that differently well i
can't get that back right all right
i changed my mind i read a new book i'm
like oh i was wrong i just told
everybody in this audience to do this
and i was wrong and i want to
communicate to people hey man
we're still figuring this out too
totally but then i know you and you're
smarter than me and you're like more on
top of stuff and so you may go like
actually john i've never been wrong i
for sure have those i just can't think
of anything from a long time ago but
i'll tell you just like two weeks ago i
answered a money question wrong on the
ramsay show oh sweet i was like with
dave too so i was like okay well are we
going to break now
there's that there's something in my
book i wish i could have fixed so i
talked about priorities and i like wrote
this pyramid tyler pointed it out and i
just we were in a crunch time but i i
talked about putting your priorities in
a pyramid
you know instead of like because most
people put it like on all on one level
like all these things and then you don't
know how to make decisions i'm like you
need to make a pyramid and everybody's
like asking all these questions about
the food pyramid like well is it the
smallest the top the least important
because it's the smallest triangle in
the butt oh god i should have just
flipped the ladder i should have made it
a lot
you just yeah it's never done the work
is never done it works just never know i
was like i should i totally should have
done a different image because
everybody's caught up on like is the
most important at the top or the most
important at the bottom i'm like
that's exactly yeah
tired just thinking about it all right
well hey thanks for being on the show
this is fun this is the most casual
interview i've ever had i love it i'm
gonna come back we're gonna answer calls
though for real i can't wait i'm gonna
set up with james because i don't trust
that you will but me and kelly and james
will work this out she's the call person
yeah
see how i did that i'll take the blame
that's what i should do right they
really just want to go home
and they're like oh my gosh we stopped
talking all right so as we wrap up every
show with the greatest song of all time
and i ask christy right number one
best-selling author mom
incredible we're doing the other one the
bass keeps running right
that's this that's the song you picked
um that is not that song yeah it's it's
how it starts oh this isn't she doesn't
even know the lyrics to her favorite
song that she actually had us print out
um so i was i was shocked that this is
the song you picked but you know what
nothing surprises me anymore with
christy right what's your middle name
brown now that's my maid brown's my
maiden name cbw
so this is it off whatever record i
don't even know what record this was
this is
a famous song
i don't know what record it is i don't
know when did this come out jake let's
get it started listen let's give context
when i'm tired as we've talked about
extensively i'll send it like a piece to
get pumped up it's good running music or
just cleaning the kitchen music whatever
you need
hear that america 2004 the black-eyed
peas dropped this this lyrical gem
on america not only on america on the
world and it fell directly
um into christie wright's heart sir and
um when as she said when she's ready to
get pumped up
she's
for making peanut butter jelly running
or cooking or anything that requires
pumped upness boom this is her go-to
and uh
i'll i'll go ahead and do the honors is
it cool i would love it if you would you
are you want to no i want you to go
ahead
black eyed peas let's get it started and
it goes like this
and the bass keeps running running and
running running and running running and
running
in this context there's no disrespect so
when i bust my rhyme you
break your necks
we got five minutes for us to disconnect
from all intellect collect the rhythm
effect i'm feeling pumped up now just
doing this
so lose an inhibition follow your
intuition listen
free your inner soul and break away from
tradition because when we beat out girl
it's pulling without christy
james
kelly i feel pumped up
i'm ready to go make some lunches go
running
cause i'm running running and running
running right here and running running
from the dr john delonay's show
[Music]